[Musique]
c'est le grand départ pour l'association
ac ph c'est la deuxième fois qu'ils sont
sélectionnés pour participer au concours
national handidanse qui se déroulera en
métropole année dernière partie avec un
groupe
on a dansé sunders bollywood je suis
aussi du goodwood en fait un essai avec
des adhérents
il a cette année on va partir avec un
autre groupe serait ségard cette fois ci
on n'envoie pas représenter ses gains et
on a choisi essaya de carrosserie d'un
homme à la main sous le thème ces
invitations paix de la réunion à l'île
de la réunion de l'ama la main bien dans
mon pays n'a soleil ils sont 12 à partir
à bourges pour représenter les couleurs
de la réunion
huit personnes nées en prothèse handicap
et puis les accompagnateurs pour cette
année ils seront accompagnés de
l'artiste laurent roselli monsieur les
gens m'a fait appel à moi parce qu'ils
ont eu un projet de faire un concours
autour de la danse de l'andi danse et
basse avec fiat et que je participe à ça
parce que ils ont choisi la chanson re
départ de donne moi la main un 60 pieds
roselli mon défunt papa et il me dit et
l'europe j'aimerais bien cette année
je suis une première j'aimerais bien
faire venir l'artiste qu'on chante
découvert je vais honorer deux fois deux
choses à la fois la chanson de mon père
est honoré le second spectacle et le
concours pour financer son voyage
l'association a fait appel à diverses
financeurs et aussi bénéficier des aides
des collectivités telles que le
département
il a fallu que je les aide qu'on essaie
d'avoir une subvention du département
qui a été
gérer ensuite j'ai demandé donc à la
mairie de sainte-marie aussi de mettre
un petit peu la main à la poche ce
qu'ils ont fait au dernier moment mais
ils l'ont fait et puis nous avons
travaillé aussi avec du sponsoring pour
que cette association puisse bénéficier
quand même d'un petit pécule pour que
arrivé là bas
ces personnes en situation de handicap
ils ont aussi le droit d'aller dans un
petit restaurant de manger ils ont le
droit aussi de prendre une crêpe une
après-midi ou de prendre une glace et
malheureusement il n'avait pas les
moyens mais moi j'ai fait un peu joué
les relations peuvent que ben ils
puissent avoir les moyens au moins de se
dire on se promène on se promène pas
voilà
[Musique]